league-wide they're down to 12 on the
covet 19 list and that's good to talk
about chris
is potential holdouts or guys who are by
all apparently holding in melvin ingram
the chargers pass rusher who is due to
make 14 million this year in the final
year of his current contract
his teammate joey bosa 27 million a year
in new money melvin ingram who has not
been practicing but who is in camp
according to daniel popper of the
athletic
is staying out of practice because he's
not happy with that deal and you know
the other reason not be happy you've got
14 million dollars in base salary this
year if there's something that happens
at some point and the season falls apart
you lose those game checks based on a 14
million dollar salary if you can do a
long-term deal that gives you a big
signing bonus that reduces your salary
this year to the minimum that limits the
amount of financial pain that you would
endure if there ultimately is a
consequence with games being lost to the
pandemic so
look i
the chargers aren't playing hardball
with melvin ingram right this was all
kept very quiet until last night yeah
bottom line is not paying him either and
i guess we should have seen this coming
anytime you're talking about taking joey
bosa to 27 million and the guy who was
joey bosa before joey bose is at 14
you're going to have a problem yeah
you're going to have a problem i mean
we've talked about this a lot right you
know this is like to me the old matt
ryan julio jones conversation we had you
know matt ryan got a new deal julio
jones looked at it and went what he's
not twice as good as me and that's where
we are here again i mean joey bosa
basically making twice as much money as
melvin ingram and melvin ingram
understands the business but he's also
like whoa i mean you know the
from where i am as a player the market
has really jumped me and yeah he's being
underpaid for the type of player he is
now now this is a dif this is a dicey
situation too you know because he is
going into year nine of his career
certainly so you know there is something
to say about that the play is not going
to continue to get better he is just you
know in that down slope of his career
and he's a guy that is a huge part of
their defense as we've talked about
right mike i mean this is a seattle
scheme it's predicated on the ability of
the front four and to get to the
quarterback so the other seven can play
coverage and you know this is one of the
better duos in football and a lot of the
success of their team you know hinges on
those two guys ability to get pressure
uh but but i i just can't imagine the
chargers at this time
diving into a long-term deal mike i
guess that's where i am with this i mean
i heard you say that i mean i agree you
know but do they throw them a sweetener
something like that a little bit more
money you know it's somehow some way to
restructure something to where they can
throw them some more money like you said
maybe up front some sort of signing
bonus some one or two year deal
something like that i mean that wouldn't
shock me if something like that got done
here if melvin ingram continues to hold
his ground
yeah i mean look you don't want to lock
yourself into a long-term deal that has
a couple of years of guaranteed money
and then three or four years after that
where the team has you until the team
doesn't want you anymore if you could
just get more money in the short term
and still preserve your ability to
become a free agent in 2021 or 2022 at
the latest
then then that would be something that
would potentially be attractive right
the core of the problem though is
there's a huge disparity now between
what bosa is making and what ingram is
making and ingram looks at it and says
the disparity is too great the player
may be better than me right now but he's
not twice the player i am
and so you just have to see how it all
plays out between melvin ingram and the
chargers but again he didn't hold out
yeah he showed up
and here's a reason to not hold out
under the new cba it's a 50 000 per day
fund and if you're on any contract other
than your rookie deal the team cannot
wave
the fine amounts when you finally show
up right i don't know how they
ultimately enforce that but it can no
longer be waived the money has to be
collected from the player um so that's a
disincentive to hold out but what you
see guys do they call it holding in the
guy shows up and my hamstring hurts my
ankle hurts you you have ways that you
can avoid putting yourself in harm's way
to avoid a major injury while you await
that financial security that you're
looking for and look i personally
i i don't know this per se yeah but i
got a pretty good feeling if joey bosa
hadn't gotten the contract he wanted
before he showed up for camp a couple of
weeks ago he was either going to hold
out or he was going to hold him then
yeah and holding
holding in is something that happens in
the nfl and it never gets talked about
because it comes with this stigma that a
guy is faking or embellishing an injury
when it's truly a business decision
chris because look hey
i don't have any security here if i
suffer a major injury if this hamstring
injury that i feel if it just goes and
my entire hamstring muscle rips apart or
it leads to some other problem as you
always say if you got the hamstring on
one side you you're running the risk of
something happening on the other side
because you're favoring that hamstring
whatever it is if you want me to throw
myself into this completely and
unequivocally and unconditionally you
got to give me the financial security
you got to take the injury risk off of
me so i'm not going gonna push my legs
if there's something wrong with my right
leg because my left leg may end up
having a problem too and i may end up
with a season-ending injury and i may
end up never making what i think i
should get so it's not a sign of a lack
of toughness but there's a nuance there
that the average fan may not understand
you're protecting your body until you
get the financial security it allows you
to say fine i'll go practice and if i
get injured i know i'm covered yeah it's
the it's the game within the game here
you know and and really
in a lot of ways like the coaches and in
the organization will respect that he's
approaching it this way because at least
he's there he's learning he's hearing
things yeah he's not taking part in the
physical activity but also what that'll
do too is drive the coaching staff crazy
to where they're like oh man they you
know they'll start sounding off to the
head coach and maybe the front office
like we got to get this guy out here
what are we going to do where are we at
where is that going so that could
actually end up putting pressure on the
organization let alone a lot of these
front office people are gonna have to
walk by melvin ingram on a daily basis
too and see him and make eye contact
with him and realize that whoa there's
this elephant in this room of this guy
wants more money and here he is he's at
work and you know he's a homegrown guy
again the chargers they've drafted some
superstars here over the last few years
and melvin ingram you know the stats
won't tell
how good the player is in my opinion
that's the one thing i know about melvin
ingram i mean you know yeah double digit
sacks no they're not always the norm
with melvin ingram but when you talk
about a run stopping defense at end and
doing everything that's you know it
entails playing defense to end the right
way in the nfl i mean he's physical he
can set the edge he can get off blocks
he can be disruptive he's really an
awesome player and i understand where
he's coming from in this because there's
some players right now hey that you look
at the d fords of the world you know you
could say yannick and gawkways uh i
could say trey flowers and look at them
and he's looking at those and going they
haven't done what i've done in this
league and he they're not as good as i
am right now he has every bit you know
the ability to make that type of case
and now it's just going to be
interesting to to see where this goes
you know the chargers got a little
wiggle room in the salary cap but uh
yeah i don't know where it goes mike i
don't know
not as much as they had before they gave
joey all that money and that's part of
the problem yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports